Hello, and welcome everyone to OSC Protocol Implementation, an Unreal Engine course for
5.3, and we're going to begin by looking at our training outline and exploring the
project files.
This course is being given by myself, Alex Coulombe, and my colleague Yujun Ye.
We are course creators for Epic Games, and we are also part of the Unreal Engine
Design Studio Agile Lens.
For the training outline, we're going to cover a wide variety of topics for Open
Sound Control.
We're going to get started by giving an overview of what Open Sound Control is and some of
the core concepts associated with it, the typical use cases, some of the software that
it gets used for.
We're then going to look at firewall and port forwarding and figuring out some
of the ways that your computer will need to be set up for that.
We'll then look deeper at the project and what's inside there and review a packaged
build that already has everything set up.
We'll then go on to a couple of exercises, first looking at how to send a message and
then sending a bundle.
We'll of course cover the differences between those.
And then wrap that up with a look at two-way communication, where rather than sending
a OSC signal in one direction, it can go both ways.
Then we'll look at packaging the project and reviewing the project build settings, as
well as launch parameters, which are a great way to be able to have different settings
when launching a project all from the same build.
And then finally, we'll look at additional recommendations and some of the ways you
can take this course content further.
Today's course comes with a zip file.
You'll see two folders in there.
One is a packaged version of the final project, and one is a U project that can be opened
in Unreal Engine 5.3.
If you open the project and it looks like this, then you're in the right project.
In the next video, we'll get started looking at OSC and understand more about what
Open Sound Control is.